So Donald Trump suddenly appeared yesterday
for a total Gong Show interview on Newsmax,
and it's funny, it's sad. It's infuriating
to some degree. It's also just very strange.
Trump doesn't seem to be making sense. He doesn't
seem to be lucid. He doesn't seem to have clarity
of mind in this interview. Let's jump right
into it. Trump not even delaying for a second,
jumping directly into the now so tired lie that he
really won the election in 2020 and no challenge
whatsoever from the host, you will notice here
are being obliterated. You know, the Democrats
are looking to virtually demolish your Second
Amendment. I said that was going to happen.
I wanted to ask about, you know, the
election. The election was a it was a rigged,
stolen election. But if this would have happened
to Democrats, you would have had a revolution.
They wouldn't have allowed it. And the Supreme
Court was did not have the courage to do what
they should have done because these elections
in the swing states, they didn't have anything
approved by the legislatures. Well, that's
right. Yeah. That's why I asked you earlier.
That's why I asked you earlier if the Republican
Party had done enough before the election to
keep some of these things from happening when
it came to voting laws and voting integrity,
which obviously all the states now are trying to
do their part with that. But it's causing a huge
problem with a lot of corporations and boycotts.
Well, no, Republicans clearly did not do enough
before the election in the sense that
they didn't suppress enough of the vote.
They did not suppress enough of the vote to win
in 2020. That's what they're now trying to make
up on lost time for. That's the genesis. That's
the impetus for the Georgia voter suppression bill
and more than 250 voter suppression bills across
the country in more than 40 states. Listen now
to Trump answering it and blaming judges finally.
Well, actually, they did and they did. And as you
know, judges didn't want to hear cases. You know,
they didn't want to be responsible for for this.
The judges didn't want to hear the case. But it's
so simple not only that people voting not only,
you know, illegal immigrants and all of the other
things, all of the ballot dumps, all of the things
that happened at three o'clock in the morning,
et cetera, to get all of that. They didn't get
approval to make all of these massive changes. And
you're not allowed to do it locally or even with
local judges. And you're going to have a state
local politicians. Yes. Should have never been
allowed in. The Supreme Court should be ashamed
of themselves for not being willing to take it on.
No pushback on anything. Mr. Trump says that
the Supreme Court should be ashamed of itself.
And the host says rights. Trump says illegal
immigrants voted and the host is silent. Illegal
immigrants can't vote. They can't even register
to vote. Trump says dead people voted. Dead people
didn't vote. It was widely examined. All these
allegations, about 10000 dead people voting.
It was investigated and there were a bunch of
buckets. But basically what you had with suppose
dead people voting was some people were accused of
voting while dead and they were alive, I believe
was Channel four from the UK, just knocked on
people's doors and said, are you dead? And they
said, no, I'm alive. And I voted. There were some
confusions between junior and senior year. So,
you know, like imagine David Pakman Junior and
David Pakman senior Jewish folks don't do junior
and senior. That's a bad example. Imagine like
Noah Smith Junior, whose dad, Noah Smith senior
is dead. Noah Smith Junior goes to vote. They
counted as a vote for Noah Smith senior. It's
a clerical error. It's still only one vote. They
voted under one name, just the wrong name. That's
just a clerical error. There were people who were
registered to vote and they died, but they didn't
vote. In other words, if you are registered to
vote and you die, you're not immediately removed
from the voter rolls, but you also don't
vote. So there were essentially, you know,
that that is just a ruse. It didn't happen.
And Trump continues to repeat it. Then this
is where it gets really weird. The topic of Major
League Baseball comes up Major League Baseball,
as we've been talking about, moving their all star
game out of Georgia and to Colorado over the voter
suppression bill in Georgia. And Donald Trump's
answer when he's asked, should we be boycotting
baseball? Trump's answer is confused. It's cloudy.
He seems to be saying baseball is inappropriate.
I don't even know what that means and that he has
a lot of trouble now finding baseball games on TV,
which he's not interested in watching
anyway. See if you can unravel the meaning
of this answer. It's all very odd.
So should we boycott baseball?
Well, I have no look, I'm just very. And
in baseball, for the last number of years,
I think it's not appropriate. You know, you
look, it's you want to find a game. It's on
it's on every channel, and yet you can't
find anything. The weirdest thing that's
used to be a nice, easy thing to follow. And you
know what I mean by that? It was on one network
and it was nice and good and beautiful. Today, you
don't even know what the hell you're watching. So
I would say boycott baseball. Why not?
What is Trump talking about here? It used to be
one network and it was nice and easy to follow.
Now it isn't. It's inappropriate. So, yeah,
let's boycott it. And I like how the host laughs.
The host laughs like she shares the experience of
having trouble finding baseball on TV. What
are they even talking about? Does anybody
understand? This sounds kind of like an old man
screaming, get off my lawn. The NBA. You know,
it's on all sorts of weird channels, NFL games.
They're no longer just on Sundays. And I can't
find those baseball games anymore. Really strange.
And it actually made me wonder as I watch this,
remember Trump's rant about, you know, you'll
have to flush toilets ten to fifteen times
if Joe Biden wins. Maybe Trump is
just confused about how toilets work.
And it's less about Joe Biden and more about
Trump's really confused because this answer
about should we boycott baseball? And Trump says,
I can't even I have trouble finding it on TV.
It seems very scrambled. So in other strange
and unusual interview from the former president
and these interviews seem to be going worse and
worse for him. They also seem increasingly less.
They're just not that Fox News is particularly
prestigious. But, you know, the primetime
interviews on Fox were replaced by middle of the
day interviews on Fox, now replaced by middle
of the day interviews on Newsmax. It's all very
strange and something doesn't sound quite right